there's no connecting themed my novels
they're mostly I try to in fact
intentionally not to do that i mean just
whatever whatever I want to do i do
sometimes their comic knowledge and
several comic novels that nothing bad
happens to anybody and I've written some
real tragic novels that started out to
be something less I mean something
different than they were they ended up
he was only different than they were
when they started but but most of my
recent novels are about people whose
lives have not turned out the way they
hope they would they would and they've
had to deal with him some of them have
dealt with him and with kind of strange
ways one of them recently a guy decided
just to remake himself as a former
Marine claimed that he won the Silver
Star in Vietnam for heroism he'd never
been in the military anybody got on eBay
got it got a little help in the Silver
Star medal to where he was a clothing
sales man in his 50s and he remade
himself he got trim learned how to cuss
really well do all the things that
Marines do and to be something that he
wasn't and I've written a couple of
novels along that line and working on
one right now in fact or kid wanted to
be something he just could be and this
one involves baseball and other things
so it is I think probably those kinds of
it may have you know I thought about to
this moment but it may go back to those
early days so they they they from the
Depression and World War two and all
those things where my father my father
was it was a really good man one of the
really best people I've ever known but
he was not quote successful he had one
little business the add a little bus
line in Kansas went bankrupt after a
year crushed him he never got over it he
never ever got over and he never he
never got the big promotion
and all that sort of stuff and I think
that left you know kind of a Death of a
Salesman there's the kind of a coating
of Arthur Miller's play over me I think
sometimes I've read it many times has
seen it many times and probably I have a
lot of friends of her contemporaries of
mine I'm now much older than some of
these guys were but who reached their
mid 50s and worked very hard to to
become the managing editor to become the
boss become whatever and they didn't
make it and they had to finally accept
the fact that they weren't ever going to
make it and that's crushing that's a
really tough thing if you've lived your
whole life toward making it that was it
that was what you were going to do no
matter what it was going to be and I'm
fascinated by that and I'm sure it's
because of my dad is because of my of
those early days and so my fiction it's
full of that kind of stuff of people
wanting to be trying like hell to be
what they couldn't
you